fabrice di vizio bonsoir fabrice ah oui
là la ilaha illa
ça va verser s'arracher les boeufs car
il s'est enrichi les montagnes oui
fabrice c'est plutôt plus calme que
d'habitude et faire moi j'ai une
question pour jean paul hamon
est ce que j'aimerais adil et l'anis à
m'en aller je voudrais juste savoir en
fait est ce que vous voudriez c'est moi
aussi j'ai eu peur je suis pas venu juge
partis très loin de vous est ce que je
voulais pas me faire cogner en tant qu
ils responsables est ce que vous voulez
le cogner jean-paul ah non bah ouais
alors ça ça vraiment
j'adore dans les saveurs si vous voulez
vous avez posé une question je vais
vous avez pas vous avez une question je
vais jouer
[Rires]
qu'est ce que dit jean paul à moi
ne pas se faire vacciner pardon mais ça
va bien jouer les irresponsables
alors jean paul répondait oui c'est un
matin à matin de bonne heure un dimanche
matin j'étais interviewé sur une
surenchère
et
papa s'appelle division
division étaient à la messe et donc il
n'a pas entendu ce que j'ai dit est donc
effectivement
effectifs dont je peux remplacer une
banque
j'étais quand même très énervé sûr pour
les gens qui que je refusais de se faire
vacciner et
et donc là j'ai dit une phrase il va
falloir il va falloir sortir la boîte à
claques et
il va falloir il va falloir sortir il va
falloir sortir la boîte à claques et
cogner sur les antilles vague c'est à
dire que ça voulait dire s'il faut tenir
alors il ya des avocats en mal de
publicité qui ont pris ça au premier
degré et qui ont dit et qui ont dit
est-ce que je suis une personne sur
lequel vous devriez cogner alors écoutez
ça m'a pas étonné de vous parce que quoi
qu'elle soit mauvaise foi vous êtes bien
en forme 1 donc là moi c'était un truc
du second degré a dit et j'avais dit on
va pas laisser comme ça les gens c'était
un moment où la vaccination patiner et
que et que les et que la laine lapide la
pandémie se développer que les
réanimations était plein et donc et
voilà donc et ça a été largement
diffusée et déformé par fabrice di vizio
nul est sa responsabilité il est habitué
ça c'était du très bon parce que c'est
tout
il n'a pas dit que ça perso je me tape
un vrai succès chez les patriots après
avoir dit sur scène il fallait sortir la
boîte à claques pour les non vaccinés
bravo alors ça c'est pas de la violence
ça me fait rire parce que pour l'instant
ouais le nexus one à l'indignation votre
signature m vous pouvez vous la mettre
d'accord
la samah la saba et ça m'a bien ça va
bien effectivement pourquoi qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est que vous avez
vous avez repris le tweet que jamais
vous avez reprises que j'avais dit vous
l'avez déformés vous l'avez vous l'avez
vous êtes plus dépouillé ouais ouais
ouais je sais bien jour des soldes 1
vous l'avez vous l'avez des formes et ça
se finit alors elle agit alors allez-y
n'est pas fini le conte du bien le camp
du bien est ce que vous connaissez bien
pour le nombre d'amis à barreaux un bar
en bar doubler celle d'octobre et madame
organisateurs réanimateur qui
effectivement est un ami de christian
les mal du tout le groupe no fake med
effectivement qui gravitaient le dr
marty j'ai beau lire ce qu'il écrit sur
twitter les retraités pourraient
décliner retraités pouvait dégager des
tuniques ce serait chouette ils sont une
partie du problème de qu'ils ont créée
et entretenue ce système de très longue
date j'ai pas fini
après rien ne dit qu'un de dit que je
les accepterai andrea parce qu'en fait
andrea c'est moi le chef c'est moi qui
décide de petits je prends donc excusez
moi mais quand on parle de la violence
des 9 axes ça c'est quoi premier élément
mais effectivement quand on est médecin
dans ce pays aujourd'hui et qu'on
appartient au camp du bien on a le droit
de tout dire de tout faire de vouloir
mettre des claques aux gens qui doivent
val qui me passe avec ce n'est pas ce
que vous comprenez si on peut pas les
convaincre à des contraintes et ensuite
pour l'instant les copains je vous
rappelle un truc que tout le monde a
oublié c'est que le mec qui se bat avec
des gars du garde du corps et dont les
gamins vont à l'école avec des gardes du
corps c'est moi
que quoique avait en tout cas pour
l'instant quand on me parle
effectivement de violence les médecins
sont ils en danger face aux anti pacs et
ben moi ce que je vous propose c'est
l'avis d'émission spéciale de savoir si
les anti vaccins qu'on veut frapper sont
eux aussi en danger face à des médecins
qui concrètement ne veulent pas d
admettre aurea qui veulent par ailleurs
effectivement sortir la boîte à claques
et les frapper parce que vous comprenez
stable dimanche matin et que le dimanche
on attendait fatigué et quand on est
fatigué après on peut frapper les gens
alors excusez moi mais la connerie elle
a pas de conte oui il faut condamner les
violences verbales que celle que tu
puisses attendant beau de personnes dans
un camp comme dans l'autre et quand
j'entends ici jean paul hamon et les
autres le niet se plaint ouvertement
d'avoir suivi des menaces après avoir
assumé pleinement jusqu'à dire que ce
n'est qu'un rêve je pense mais n'a pas
de relation que sais-je que c'est oui
ag lance aussi où elle est maintenant
merci c'est fini on peut parler là parce
que là franchement il n'y a aucun aucun
réanimateurs leurs animateurs excédé
qu'à passer qu'à passer des mois avec
des horaires pas possible avoir cannes
et les gens à réaliser des arrêts et
demi des gens que le réanimateur puisse
avoir un moment désespoir en tout genre
oh ça va bien là
ça m'a bien un col red qui ce qui là
qu'ils aillent faire seulement une demi
journée en réanimation il va voir ce que
c'est un devoir 95% des gens d'en
vacciner que les gens de des antilles
ont été obligés de choisir je choisirais
pour autant entre ce qu'ils allaient
réaliser non pas c'est donc là là le
réalisateur de leurs animateurs excédé
puisse dire que le réacteur est cédée
puisse avoir cette phrase mais personne
aucun médecin on ne refusera de soigner
qui que ce soit vous le savez bien on
peut parler de ça comme ça entre nous
quand les mecs sont excédés alors
effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux
pour se méfier mais mais là c'est vrai
que c'est insupportable qu'on dit mais
quand on voit des gens qui qui qui
meurent des détectives de 50 ans qui
sont pas vaccinés et quand on voit que
le lot des gens qui sont en réanimation
95% que carling nous dit qu'il a
rapatrié cents personnes des antilles
100 personnes en réanimation
l'équivalent de deux airbus j'imaginais
donc cesser c'est vrai que quand les
gens ne réalisent pas l'importance de la
vaccination conques ont comparé ce qui
s'est passé là il ya eu de la
contamination énorme en france mais les
les réanimateurs n'ont pas été débordée
cette fois ci alors qu aux antilles et à
tahiti les gens ont été débordés donc si
vous voulez c'est clairement entre la
vaccination dit c'est du gâchis et les
gens sont désespérés de voir ça c'est
tout